jojojura et un millier de camionnette
ford f 150 stationnée sur la piste de
course du kentucky
malheureusement pour les nombreux
amateurs elles ne sont pas à vendre en
fait elles ne sont pas vendables il leur
manque des puces électroniques
indispensables à un fonctionnement
sécuritaire
les 4 points et 3 km circuit était
rempli de f150
on est à étudier des solutions pour
l'avenir presque toute l'industrie
automobile mondiale manque cruellement
de composants électroniques pour
compléter plusieurs de ses modèles model
incomplet ça veut dire qu'il peut
fonctionner les
vitres électriques non mais la puce
épaules on peut pas se servir des vitres
électriques un moteur d'essuie glace on
propose servir du moteur d'essuie glace
parce que bien comprendre qu'un véhicule
automobile on a entre 30 et 100 puce
dépendamment des modèles et évidemment
s'ils manquent cette nuit plus on peut
pas compléter le véhicule donc on doit
fermer les usines suite à la coved les
constructeurs n'ont pas prévu la reprise
du marché si vite et comme il pratique
le concept du juste à temps avec leurs
nouvelles commandes de puces ils ont dû
passer en dernier à cause de la pandémie
justement parce que les gens la maison
fait quoi on acheter des ordinateurs ont
acheté des consoles de jeux beaucoup de
gens qui ne faisait pas de télétravail
qui avaient un ordinateur au travail et
pas la maison sans acheteur pour
travailler donc les fonceurs de plus
auraient été débordées littéralement et
puis il y a les fermes de minage de
crypto monnaie comme le bitcoin qui
consomment de plus en plus d'ordinateurs
semi conducteurs puce électronique
microprocesseurs circuits intégrés c'est
le vocabulaire d'un secteur industriel
qui ne cesse de prendre de l'importance
compare parfois maintenant à au pétrole
dans les années 80 c c'est vraiment
utilisé dans tous les secteurs et là
vous voyez avec par exemple l'adoption
la 5g ça va encore augmenter la demande
de puces de l'internet des objets tous à
fond
on a utilisé plus dans notre vie tous
les jours dans pleins d'objets
différents et des choses qui avant
n'avait pas de plus maintenant utilisent
des puces ses débuts ce qu'ils sont
toujours plus évoluées donc
effectivement c'est devenu un composant
central de nos économies et donc dans c
est ce qu on appelle les chaînes de
valeur c'est un ingrédient indispensable
de ses chaînes de valeur et les
fournisseurs ils ne sont pas nombreux
les deux plus grands sont en asie qui
produit 80% des semi conducteurs du
monde se sont samsung en corée du sud et
tsmc de taïwan ils sont débordés et leur
dominance est telle que le président joe
biden est très inquiet et leur demande
de construire des usines aux états unis
dans les faits
la présidente de taiwan en profite pour
offrir aux européens et aux pays
démocratique un approvisionnement solide
et m on échange bien sûr d'une
protection contre la chine pour ne pas
devenir un deuxième quand les enjeux
géopolitiques sont immenses la chine est
en retard sur la technologie de semi
conducteurs elle essaie de rattraper
malgré les sanctions américaines qui la
prive d'éléments industriels
stratégiques
ceci dit tous les grands producteurs
dépendent d'une seule compagnie basée en
hollande à la frontière belge à sml qui
fabrique les machines qui leur
permettront de produire des puces de
plus en plus petit est puissante grâce à
une technologie unique que seule elle
maîtrise l'impression de
microprocesseurs par lithographie à
ultraviolets extrêmes on produise des
puces électroniques
ti stuff plus la formation qui vont plus
vite ça veut dire qu'ils calculent plus
rapidement qu'ils consomment moins
d'énergie dont qui sont plus qu'ils sont
plus que c'est ça que font nos c'est ça
que font nos machines et c'est ça notre
engin quand je maintenu avec plusieurs
années d'avancé sur tout le monde reste
à produire encore davantage de puces
pour en finir avec la pénurie pas facile
pourquoi est-ce qu'on peut pas laisser
dire on construit une usine simplement
parce qu'une usine ça coûte à peu près
10 milliards de dollars et ça prend
plusieurs plusieurs années avec
construit on peut pas juste comme ça
décidé on peut choisir d'investir là
dedans et de construire des usines mais
les effets de cette nouvelle usine on
les verra dans un ou deux ans pour
l'homme en main les constructeurs
automobiles benoit charette revient du
salon de l'auto de munich le premier
dans le monde depuis la pandémie l'effet
du manque de semi conducteurs était
évident du côté de mercedes on travaille
beaucoup à
réduire le nombre de puces dans les
véhicules en ce moment parce que bon
mercedes est parmi évidemment les
constructeurs d'un autre technologie et
on a besoin d'énormément puce dans ces
véhicules là on va dire est ce qu'on
peut avoir un module qui vont opérer un
certain nombre de fonctions puis est ce
qu'on peut mettre juste deux puces au
lieu d'en avoir dix essais pas le cas
pour mars ont eu un peu plus de
général les pénuries ne font pas que des
malheureux
celle-ci n'échappe à la planète va
perdre un peu près huit millions et demi
de véhicules qu'on aura pas fabriqué en
2021 à cause de la pandémie donc c'est
des chiffres qui sont quand même énorme
et ça ça fait monter les prix du neuf et
de l'occasion d'un verre par exemple un
véhicule très récent cci au parena
bombay le propriétaire pour vendre ses
véhicules la plus chère que ce qui a
payé il y en a pas donc les gens qui
veulent en avoir sont prêtes à mettre le
prix donc cette situation
annonce un retour à la normale peu
probable avant 2023 disent les experts
[Musique]